what does well everybody welcome to part
7 of our intermediate Python programming
tutorial series in this tutorial we're
going to be talking about the built-in
function enumerate so what a numerate is
going to do is it's going to return a
tuple containing the basically the count
along the way and then the object itself
or the item itself that you were
iterating over so you use a numerate
unnhhh iterable so where's my mouse
first let's say we're just going to say
an example equals left right up and down
and what we're going to say is we'll
just do will do for I in range Len
example print I example I so this is an
example of code that you might find
yourself writing to produce the
following like basically any time you
find yourself or I would say most of the
time I'm trying to think of an example
where I've not been screwing up when I
do this but pretty much any time you're
going to say for I in range of a length
of something you're probably doing it
wrong okay so just keep that in mind
I've done it probably no I know I've
done in some of the tutorials for sure
just because like I just never use a
numerator I just don't think about it
but lately in my own code I've been
trying to use a numerator just because
it exists and you should do it so
anyways this is not the right way to go
about it instead what you should say is
something like this for I J in and
numerate example print IJ I'll print the
other one just to do it I guess but as
you can see this one ended here or this
the first one this is the second one
exact same output just a little
holy nur it makes a little bit more
sense it's the way it's supposed to be
you're also not doing like this range
Len nonsense you just don't need to so
don't do it so that's one example of
enumerate for most people that's
probably all you need to do you can use
enumerate over a dictionary and a lot of
other iterables I would show you a
dictionary you can go to the sample code
if you really want to see it but it's
basically the exact same thing as we
just did here I just don't wanna make a
dictionary but I will also show that you
can easily because we have tuple what
can you do with basically lists of
tuples you can do the following you can
say new dictionary or it build a
dictionary equals dict enumerate and
then will enumerate the example and now
let's print new dipped there we go so
basically in this case we've created a
dictionary where the key is that index
value of enumerate and then the value is
the thing that was in the list now of
course since I second I go I just told
you I didn't want to make a dictionary
look at that
we got a dictionary so we could just do
this we'll do this comprehension print i
J okay or JK that's fine for let's see
print IJ k 4i j in enumerate new dibs so
here we just get 0 0 1 1 2 2 2 3 3
because that is our dictionary was the
keys were just 0 1 2 3 and so on so that
was just not you're probably never going
to enumerate over a dictionary that has
keys like that but just showing that you
can do it over a dictionary if you so
chose so that's all on enumerate it's
just a really simple addition to the
Python standard library something useful
mostly for when you find yourself in
this case this is
just always when you would use a
numerate for the most part I'm sure
there's lots of other times you might
use it or things that you ask that you
might do but for the most part this is
when I found myself doing what I should
have been doing enumerate so in the next
tutorial we're going to be talking about
the zip function but if you do have any
questions comments concerns on enumerate
feel free to loom below otherwise I'll
see you the next tutorial